Sometimes you've got to dig deep. Sometimes you've got to look in the glass and you've got to ask yourself, how much do I want this? Why did I show up today? Why did I want to put it all on the line? What are my goals and what am I willing to do to reach them? Now what you look at me and I want you to repeat. S M A R T L E S S smart less smart Less Smart Less Let's Go! Smart Smart Smart Smart Less Smart
Are we rolling Jimmy. Shon. Yeah. Shon. Shon. Shon. Wait, you guys, this is crazy that you're speaking British accents. Go ahead. Why are you doing?
I know, I know. Wait, Shon, you London. Oh my gosh. No. Well, Jason's not. Neither of you go. That's both of this terrible. No, that now that's great. It's going to be so insulting to our guest. But wait, let's get.
Of course, is our guest British? Oh, no. What, what, what made you think that the 50 times that he went like, I don't know. Wait, what are you saying? Seani, next week, I know we should have do this on the podcast, but dinner in New York, yes, Tuesday. Guys, what are we doing? What are you doing? You're not doing anything. You're staying in home. Yeah, Tuesday, 100% in New York, dinner, right?
Let's hold on, let's hear we're making plans. You guys have your roller dicks is out, you wanna wait for that? Or enter it? Oh, I'm sorry. Do you wanna talk about golf? No, I just, I'm not gonna make You guys have your roller dicks is out. You wanna wait for that? Or enter it? Oh, I'm sorry. Do you wanna talk about golf? No, I just, I'm not gonna make plans with my buddy on the listeners time.
Hey, what are the rules? Jay, why don't you come out and join us? Finally, come out. No, because I'm married. I've had two children and it would just be too disruptive. But they won't, they won't know that. What's in New York? To New York.
To New York. I already tried to get him to come to New York and he just gave a classic Jason. No, I don't want to. Yeah, well my feelings. And I apologize for that. I've had long discussions with my wife over the last 12 hours and what I need to work on is checking in with other people that are associated with the plan that might not see it through the prism of one. There you go. So maybe ask them what they would like. Right.
And then, you know, because I just think, well, they're asking my opinion. So it's just about me, how do I personally, well, my personal opinion is, no, I wouldn't like to do that. But if I check in with you, I might change that, you know? Right. If you go like, or maybe, and you can,
even before you check in, you can go like, or you maybe, and you can even before you check in, you can go like, hey, maybe this is something that somebody else wants, and it's not just, I don't want, I want, I don't want, I want. Yeah. And you go like, There's a we in this world. Yeah.
You know what I mean? Yeah, no, it's a great note, and I think I'm learning it just in time at 54. Jade, do you want to go out to dinner next week? Yeah, no, thanks. All dog news. I'm not going to be in town, but if you guys want to zoom me in from the table, that would be a right.
I love to watch you. Wait, I want to say one thing. As you know, smartness media launched bad dates, which is now right now, with Jameela Jamil, which is fantastic. It's a great show. But we have a new name. and just Jack and Will launches June 22nd. Well, I wanted to say that so that you didn't have to promote your own show. No, no, sorry, it's Will. It's our show.
It's our show. No, no, no, no. Will, do you and Jack Black are doing a podcast? No, you do. No, no. It's the characters Jack and Will from Will and Grace. So it's Sean Hayes and Eric McCormick doing. We're doing, we're doing, we're doing, we're doing, we're doing, we're doing, we're doing Will and Grace. So it's Sean Hayes and Eric McCormick doing.
We're doing it. We're doing it. And it's a rewatch podcast of Will and Grace. I'm, Sean, I'm getting to it. I want to say it so you don't have to. So you can take in all the praise you deserve. Do you know what I'm most excited about with that podcast is that? Sanger.
No, to coming on. My, my daughter. No, actually, actually, listen, I think this, this means I to coming on. My daughter actually, listen, I think this means I'm coming on. My daughter's, your good friends and my granny and maple, 16 and 11 have never seen Will and Grace and their bananas about you. So I just keep thinking, wait till they see you, do your thing.
And so this is gonna give us a great chance to start watching the show together. Yeah, that's a great. And then listening to the podcast, uh, doing the rewatch. And then coming on, maybe I'll bring them both on and we'll give you, we'll give you notes. That would be, you know, so fun. You guys aren't locked yet on those episodes, right? If we, if we recording them now, we recorded a bunch of, no, no, no, sorry, the willing grace episodes, if we give you notes, you know, we can rest your stuff. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. It'll match. It'll match. By the way, it's the 25th anniversary of willing grace this year. Right? Silver anniversary. Isn't that crazy? Yeah.
Is that over five years ago? You know what? Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh Jimmy we're always yesterday. Yeah. Oh, no way. Yeah. Where at Pine Golf? He was playing with Al Michaels or other good friend. He said, say hi to Shane. I think you guys are doing a good job on the, on the, he said, he said, Shane, I loved working with Shane. Yeah. He was the best. I'll never forget him. He said, yeah. He said, never forgets the best. And we, and we said, we, he said, I'll never get him. We said, who? And he said, what? Do you know what I mean? So Tracy, that's the director of Willing Grace. Well, he's a friend and, you know, he's directed every episode of Willing Grace.
That's right. I've listened to his episode, just know he's, yes. So I want to get done with this so we can get to our guest because he's been so kind to wait. So it premieres on June 22nd. It's all in the episodes out every week, or here to week early in Amazon, or the Wondry app. And it's super exciting.
And it's really, really fun. I'd never seen Watch The Show really after being on it because that my excuse was like, I was there. Like I was there. You didn't watch the one it was on for America? I didn't really. I mean, I remember like bits and pieces, but Eric watched it a little too much. So it's kind of, it's really fun to do the show with them. Anyway, it's just jacking well.
Yeah. Our guest today makes me laugh so much. He's actually born the same year as me, which means he's born the same year as Will. 53 year old man from England. Yes. I consider him British royalty, since he's such a major figure in the comedy world and sci-fi, which as you know, is royalty to me. a major figure in the comedy world, and sci-fi, which as you know is royalty to me. He undoubtedly has both Spielberg and Tom Cruise on Speed Dial. Oh, I know what it is. But it's greatest achievement who is reaching the holy grail of nerd and status.
That's a real thing for the nerd trifecta. As some people call it, this happens when you portrayed prominent characters on Doctor Who, Star Trek, and Star Wars. Guys, it's the brilliant Simon Pegg. I knew it was gonna be Simon. Simon! I knew it was the brilliant Simon Pegg. I knew it was going to be Simon. Simon! I knew it was Simon.
I knew it. I knew it. Well, you didn't have that will. I did. I knew it was Simon. What did you say it? I don't know. It was just, you didn't want to spoil it.
But isn't it a crazy guy started talking and brought a fact down with those pipes? I thought they were really good. Listen to that. You didn't. No, you didn't. No, you didn't. Simon. I know. Hey, Simon. Hey, man. Great to see you didn't. No, you didn't. No, you didn't. No, you didn't. You didn't voice, Simon.
I know. I know. Hey, Simon, hey, man, great to see you. Hey, you two, I'm such a fan of this podcast. I feel kind of you're not strange, but you've never. No, I've never met you. Absolutely have. I have.
Oh, then show them. We've never met, and I just want to say I'm a big show in Heistfield. Well, likewise, I'm massive. By the way, before we get going on all of that, I want to say Simon, I see over your right shoulder spaced, which was the show that you and Edgar did. And I want to talk about space. I loved, as you know, and I've told you, I've embarrassed you before, how much I loved spaced. And for a number of reasons, but walk me through a little because that was your guys first, like a big thing that you all got to you and Edgar and Nick and Nick too. Nick wasn't really an actor before that right? So I mean I remember
you telling me this story once years ago. No, he was a waiter. Yeah, and yeah, I moved to London with my girlfriend and she went to work at this Mexican restaurant called Chiquitos. I don't know if you've ever eaten Mexican in London. It's amazing. Um, I don't know for it. She came up from work and stuff. I think it's work. Wacomole started. It actually is where it's invented.
Cricklewood. Um, it, he's really funny and he wants to be a stand-up. And I was kind of dabbling with stand-up at the time. And, and we sort of, uh, we met. And, and he was the funniest, is the funniest human being I know. I tried, he tried stand up, it didn't really fit for him, it couldn't convert his hilariousness into a routine. But we came to, we got space and I said, look, come and be in this TV show with me and we can hang out. And he had this character, he'd come up with this sort of this army guy called Mike.
And we wrote it into the show and convinced the producers that he was an actor, which he wasn't. And I think there was another guy called Nick Frost on our sort of equity. So they looked him up and said, yeah, he checks out. And that's how we got into the show and how he started his career. Wow, that's amazing.
And then you, what happened with you and Ed girl? Like how did you guys get that show off the ground? We, Jessica, Heinz and I, wrote it. We, Jessica, worked with Edgay before. And he was like the only guy that we could imagine who could sort of make the show. And he came along and we put it together. And he showed us all his storyboards and stuff
and we were kind of just blown away because it's got this incredible vision. And we took it to Channel 4 and they liked... This is a really lucky... We were so lucky, you know, as a time when you could sort of just pitch something and they go, yeah, sure, let's do it. And we were on right after Friends
and it was this strange sort of, slightly surreal show, but it really found its audience. And that was where the idea for Sean kind of came about and where our sort of relationship began. So yeah, that was the beginnings of it all. Do you know the number of things that you and Nick and Edgar have done together? I could probably count them, but it might be boring for the podcast.
I don't know, let's go for one. It doesn't. Two. Probably what we did to space, then the three corner to films, and then we did Tintin. Tintin. Yeah, like five or six, I guess. And we've done other stuff as well.
I wanted to ask you about, because like, you know, your credits, you know, like talk about fandom. I'm like a creepy stalker fan of yours because you're in everything I love, right? So I, you're like the fandom you're associated with by default. How often do you check? Because you're not on social media, like you're not on anything. How often do you check in to see what's being said if anything or do you avoid the internet? Because you, you know Because you have those iconic stories that you constantly tell from everything you're working on,
but you have no outlet to put them. So people must just be like, you know, salivated. What have got an Instagram now? Are you do? And I follow, I follow SmartLess. That's more like, Oh, you guys. What?
Yeah. What a great, I was kind of upset when I said, What are we saying? Oh, we'll follow your back. What have we been saying on there? Yeah, I was kind of upset when I said, what are we saying? Oh, follow your pack. What have we been saying on there? Yeah, whatever. Terrific. But do you ever look at what people are saying or do you not, you're like, I can't, I don't
care, I'm not. Sometimes, I was on Twitter for a while and then I left that because it just felt like, it just felt like a party where everybody was drunk and angry. Yeah. Yeah. I sort of checked out of that. I've kept the account just for sort of info. Twitter's like my house growing up just drunk and angry. Yeah.
I remember you and Nick, and the reason I got, the person who showed me who actually set up my Twitter account, physically did it on my phone with Pete Seraphine, which, I was a Pete. Yeah. And we were in Vancouver. And I kept and I was arguing against it. It's like 2009. Yeah, 2009 or 10. What month? What month? It was actually. No, no, Simon, he knows this stuff. It's crazy. No, it's no joke. I'm not joking. Just give him two seconds. He'll drop it. It was February 2010. It probably was.'ll drop you. It was February 2010. That's crazy.
It probably was. It probably was. It just inverts me every time. Simon, did you, so you're born in 1970 on Valentine's Day before I get into all your career stuff because I can't wait. Do you have any crazy story about hooking up on Valentine's Day, which is your birthday, and it's turning into something? If it's a bad date, say it for our sister podcast, bad dates. No, I spoke to Jimi LeRubat doing that,
but I don't have any bad dates, really. I don't like it. I think of anything that would make the podcast fun. It's the mailman who delivers my birthday cards thinks I'm a stud, obviously, but otherwise, you know, you get it, really. That's hysterical. All right, so you were born.
I thought bad dates was more about like December 7th, 1941. She was. That's so stupid. That is so dumb. That was a terrible date. Wait, so, okay. So you were born Simon Beckenham, but why did I tell me about that? Well, my mum remarried.
My parents splits up. My dad, I kept in touch with Well, my mom remarried. My parents split up. My dad, I kept in touch with my dad, as which was good. There's a, I'm sorry to gloat, Sean. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. See, I do listen to the folk, I guess. Simon, I think your dad just had a slower car.
That was a lot. Yeah. By the way, if your dad runs into my dad, let me know. They're good friends. Yeah. When my mom remarried, I remember I was seven and I remember thinking I don't want to have a different name to my mom.
And she married Richard Pegg. And I just made that decision. I thought I want to have the same name as my mom. I don't want to come into my school and then to say, hello Mrs. Beckingham and her have to correct the teacher. I remember making that little calculation when I was a kid, which is strangely adult.
Will, do you have a shunt? Sean, why was gonna say that? Sean, didn't you one time say on the podcast, hey, to anybody out there, if you happen to run into my dad, make sure to reverse and run into him again. Totally. Ha, ha, ha, ha. Whoa.
By the way, we were gonna talk about this a while ago. It's total sidebar. Sure. My dad showed up to Good Night a while ago. It's total sidebar. Sure. My dad showed up to Good Night Oscar in Chicago. What? Yeah. I knew that. Crazy.
But he didn't come backstage during that. I didn't see him. Well, I guess he didn't like the show. He'd probably hate it. That's very strange. No, isn't that what you're supposed to infer? No, and then he showed up on my sister's Facebook and said, I love the show. Yeah, but he said something weird.
He said something like an Oscar Levant, just like I remembered him. But no, like that's my son. Oh, so he was like humble bragging. No, my son just like I remembered him. That's my son. He's got a clear memory of Oscar Levant, but he does of you. He doesn't remember you waving from the window. Yeah.
You should show up to his house as Oscar Levant. You go. How have you been? Oh my God. It's really funny. Okay, so, but wait, this is what's so cool. I love this. I did this exact same thing as you Simon.
So, you started acting at like 16. You went to Strafford upon Avan, but you just study English literature and theater. But as a boy, you would listen to John Williams' scores. And I used to listen to him all the time, and so did my husband, Scotty, I'm obsessed. Yeah. He's the greatest. It was one of my most sort of, my priortist moments, I think, ever in my career, with Tintin was seeing my name come up on the screen and then music by John Williams. Yeah, that's insane. Yeah, that's insane. You know, because for me, it was, I used to listen to it
and imagine myself in movies and it was the soundtrack to my childhood, you know, I loved him. I still do, he's the most incredible component. We go, Skydien, I go every year to Hollywood Bowl to watch him conduct with the lightsabers. Did you ever been there? It's insane. Oh, I wish I had.
Oh, you got to come. You got to kind of alienate to Jason. Oh, fuck, man come. You got to just kind of alienate Jason. Oh, fuck man. Inverted again. You know, John Williams plays a few holes a golf every day at four o'clock. Still? He's 19.
Yeah. Yeah. He drives down the hill and his golf cart and he hits it a few times and that's his routine. And he said, we saw him about two weeks ago and just out of, barely, he just barely ever say, if you see Sean Sean Hayes tell me that asshole. That's interesting. That's interesting. We weren't sure, but we were pretty sure that's what it was.
Yeah. Stop nerding out of my music. Sounds like a fucking loser. Stop fucking mentioning it. Stop identifying his entire fucking life face of my fucking music to my movies and get a fucking life and have some real life experiences. Other than talking about fucking nerd movies. Wow, you had a lot to say.
Was that in between the whole? That's all I caught. He kept going. We've Simon, what do you have a favorite John Williams score? The Impost drives back. Oh yes, of course. Without a favorite John Williams score? The Empire Strikes Back. Oh, yes, of course. Without a doubt. That's more favorite.
I love that. Is that held up as one of the all-time greats in that sort of, in the John Williams canon? I think so. I mean, you know, it's just, it's got so many sort of classic themes on it. And, you know, it's the first time we had the Imperial March and and and and and and and all these sort of incredible. It's just a beautiful, beautiful school. Yeah, that's pretty much mutually agreed that that's the best
of the Star Wars movies, right? Absolutely. I think so. And they're really in what nine? I can't remember nine. It's just been a lot. Well, 77 it was 80. Like we were finally doing I and will were like 10 or 11.
Can I just say this? Can I just say I hope they make nine more. You know what? I probably they probably will. They are. They are. I saw the first one in 1977. And if we've talked about this with somebody,
I saw the first the first one four times in the theater. It's the only time I've ever seen. And then and then I start because you know, I got older. Um, hey, so... So, let me just... Okay, so I mean, I want to go back, hang on, I'd do one... One turn date? I turned date. And once I turned date, I was like,
what am I fucking doing? I'll never get laid. Oh, my God. And we will be right back. Smartless. Get support from Viori clothing. Tired of sacrificing style for comfort or vice versa? Look no further than Viori.
The performance clothing brand that combines both. Viori offers the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet y'all, making it the perfect investment in your happiness. From joggers to leggings to crew next, beauty has everything you need to stay comfy and stylish, no matter what you're doing. For instance, me, here, talking into a microphone, I'm sitting on a couch, it's not incredibly comfortable.
I need clothes that are more comfortable than the couch I'm sitting on. And with Viori, I've got that. I'm going to Viori Cloud right now. You know, for listeners, they're offering 20% off your first purchase. Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viori.com-smartless. That's V-U-O-R-I-.com- slash smart list. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any US orders over $75 and free returns. Go to
Viori.com slash smart list and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. Ciao. Glow Thing. Ciao. for in the morning with all the lights off, trying not to wake up your roommates, or the recommendations that you share with your friends on the top six comedy podcasts that are the best to listen to on your way to the gym and back, or even your new haircut, which may or may not be an epic bull cut from the 90s. And hopefully it is.
Everything that makes you, you makes all the difference. State Farm believes insurance should work the same way. Now hear me out here. Your plan, your coverage selections can be personalized by you. And the ability to choose the plan you want by picking the options that fit you. Like choosing to bundle your home and auto policies is what the State Farm Personal Price Plan is all about. Getting the coverage you want at an affordable price just for you.
So are you ready to make things personal? I bet you are. Call or go to statefarm.com today to create your State Farm Personal Price Plan. Prices vary by state, options selected by customer, availability and eligibility may vary. That's all. I'm not afraid to tell you, we get support from Audible, okay? It's the home of storytelling. Now, I'm not, you know, a great reader, okay? I've for a bunch of reasons that I'm not going to bore you with.
But so this audible these these people they they're on to something here. All right, I may not read, but I will listen. Now, you're going to discover thousands of podcasts from popular favorites to exclusive new series. You're going to you're going to find guided wellness programs with audible. You're going to find theatrical performances is comedy and exclusive audible originals from top celebrities renowned experts and exciting new voices in audio. The Audible app makes it easy to listen anytime, anywhere while you're traveling, working out, walking, doing chores, you decide. All right? Now, for instance, this book, the Suttler Art of Not Giving A Fuck by Mark Manson, this is a potential key to life.
It is, you know, they talk about on the show, the sexy indifference is a obnoxious term, but it's better said by Mark Manson here or better heard on Audible. New members can try Audible for 30 days. Visit audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500. That's audible.com slash smartless or text smartless to 500-500 to try Audible free for 30 days audible.com slash smartless. And now back to the show. Simon, I remember before we met, which was many, many, many moons ago, if you remember, I picked you up somewhere, and you were staying at Lermitage, and we went over there and had the best time. That's right.
The first time we hung out. I remember, I was, you know, because I'd seen Edgar had told me about rest of the development. And I'd resisted it for a while. I kind of didn't know what to do. I was like, I was know, because I'd seen Edgar had told me about arrest development and I'd resisted it for a while. You know when you're saying sort of in comedy and I know you resisted it forever Sean, but I was like, you know you kind of resent stuff when you told it's good. Yeah, oh yeah, you've got to see this show, it's incredible.
And I'll give it a look and I'd sort of didn't. Yeah, I've got to see this show, it's incredible. And I'll give it a look, and I didn't. I've done those. Eventually, I begrudgingly watched it. And I just sort of, you know, sometimes, as a funny person, you watch comedy, like somebody watching a physics lecture, you just sort of be not. Waiting to know I like it. Yeah.
This is it. This is it. Why the fuck do anything ever again? This is too fucking good. Jason and I at one of our Sunday dinners sat down and pretty much almost all the same things neither Jason and I have seen it. It's like a list that we both made. It's not because I don't want to know if you overwhelmed it to get started. Well, sometimes it feels like homework, which is, which is a bummer. It comes to the slight pressure, doesn't it?
It does come with pressure. And then because yeah, and you have shows that are really good that are mutual. Friends have done and you're like, fuck, I should watch it. Everybody says it's great. And part of me was like, I don't want to watch it also. I don't want to have an opinion in case I run into them. It's like, it's like I want to see somebody on Broadway. And then after the show, you got to go up and you got to be like, yeah, you were great. Sean, like whatever, just for lack of another, whatever, whatever you got to say, whatever the name of the person is, you've got. But wait, Simon, Sean was in, by the way, if you're in New York, go see it, I'm not joking. I have to say, I'm going to be, I'd love to come, Sean. Honestly, I'm going
to be there with mission in, in July. Oh, great. Come on. He's incredible. Yeah, it's sweet. But Simon, we first met and I had just seen Sean of the dead. And that movie for me stands out. And I've watched it recently with my kids and it's, and it's holds up because it's legitimately great and fun to see with the kids. Yeah, and I found it so inspiring at that time. I felt like you guys were doing something that not a lot of other people were doing. You were, it was smart and it was silly
and it was, and it was really tight. Whenever I saw, right, whenever I saw you will, whenever that movie came out, it's all you talked about to me, all the time. I feel, for real. For real, I still hold it up is such a great Every moment of it the writing is really good. It's really well shot. It's really well directed It's really incredibly acted like every single moment of it man
And that must have been such a huge turning point for you for Sean of the dead Yeah, well, I was absolutely was because it you know, we got some Some sort of exposure over there, and a lot of cool kind of directors came into back for our go, and we managed to get a theatrical release over there, thanks to, I think it was thanks to ANTIKAL NEWS, Harry Nolz's website. Oh, wow. And so, yeah, and so coming over, and not to bat it back to you guys,
but I kind of felt the same thing about arrested. You know, it was like, these guys, we all say, Nick and I always say, people know something. If you see someone who gets it, who is kind of, you feel like they're the same kind of person as you, you say, hey, they know something. And it was, you guys were just doing something that was just so that and, and it was, it was inspirational. And I always, and also, sure, not to leave you
out, I always thought on watching Will and Grace, because you always kind of, you know, not too much, but you all stole that show, I thought, for sure. And I always thought, I'm sure he knows something, because Will and Grace is a big, you know, it was, it was a network, common, it a big, you know, it was a network comedy. It was massive. You know, it wasn't sort of an alternative kind of thing, even though it was an incredibly progressive show. And then you popped up on like Port Landeer or something and I was like, yes, I knew it. I knew you said. Yeah, I love that show. By the way, he's so funny. You say that and it's so true, Sean, you did steal that show all the time.
Well, amongst a bunch of scene dealers, you were a scenes dealer. I remember Nick has one of those, I hold Nick is one of those guys. He's so naturally frosty, so naturally funny. And just for really quick, for Tracy, Nick Frost is a comedian actor. He collabries, hot fuzz, brawl, the world's end, your bestie. Hot fuzz, my the worlds and your bestie. Hot Fuzz, my God, you're a great movie. Hot Fuzz. And we were, once I'm standing outside this restaurant in LA and I was having a cigarette
with Nick and there were these two like really douchey guys. I don't know if this story will translate standing right there. And we, as we walked, they were just having the worst conversation, LA conversation. As we went inside, Nick goes, all right, talk to you later to the audience. Complete strangers. I didn't even know them. We hadn't talked a little bit at all. And as he's opening the door, he just looked at them and went, all right, talk to you later. To the other, it's completely strange. I didn't even know them. We hadn't talked a little bit at all. And as he's opening the door, he just looked at the window and I talked to him.
It was so funny. Fuck me. And it just, it was so naturally funny. And it made me laugh like driving home. It made me laugh like a kid thinking about it. Will you love that dry sense of humor, that British sense of humor? Was there, was there a lot of that up in Toronto at being, you know, British colony at one point like maybe, I was always
a fan. I know I've been accused of being an angle file for many years and I do, I do enjoy. I just think that there's something to, you know, when I was 17, I saw with nail and I the first time. And I was like, this, this is the kind of shit I like. And I don't know, it's always just seem smarter. And again, I know so many funny, smart, amazing American. But the style of that just never asks for a laugh. No, you know, it makes you, yeah. You just go right.
I heard you once described your Nick's relationship to my fair lady or something, like, what's the comparison? What is that? Yeah, he was like this kind of rough around the edges, Oike, and I was this university graduate who'd moved to London from Bristol and found him in an Mexican restaurant and taught him in the ways of, you know, high culture.
Very, very. Sure. I mean, Nick was, you know, high culture. Very, very... Sure, I mean, Nick was, you know, he was like... He was, he would be the first to say he was like a little thug, but he was just so gifted, so funny, in a way that still to this day he makes me laugh. Like, you know, when I listen to you guys, it reminds me of my relationship with Nick and Edgar just because it just runs on laughter
and it never gets tiring or boring. It's constantly hilariously funny. Well, and respect, like mass every spec. Yeah, we had a big dinner years ago. By the way, you're gonna fucking freak out when I tell you this, you guys are gonna be so bummed out because I think it was November 2005. And I mean, I can't.
In London. And we had that big dinner with a bunch of us Simon. And it was me and Amy and you guys and Darren Brown, the magician. Yes. Did you remember that? Yeah, of course. Yes, long time ago. And I think, did I tell this story about who,
about saying whether or not you could be hypnotized? Did I tell this hip and tell? No. So we were at this big dinner and Simon and, I guess, Darren wanted to come. He was a fan of arrest development because he liked, he's a magician or whatever. And there were a bunch of guys there.
Who else is there? He wanted to meet an illusionist. Yeah, he did. Joe Cornish, I think, was there. A bunch of them. And Pete and I asked around the table, I said to Darren Brown, the hypnotist, his magician, whatever I said, can you tell if somebody's really susceptible to being hypnotized and being persuaded?
And as we went around, I said, everybody go around the table and say whether or not you think you, because he sort of said, yeah, I can kind of tell. And so everybody went around the table and I remember I said, we went around, I said, everybody go around the table and say whether or not you think you, because he sort of said, yeah, I can kind of tell. And so everybody went around the table and I remember I said, like, I definitely could be persuaded to do probably anything. We ran around, I never had different answers. But I remember Amy Polar at the time going, there's no way, you can't get me. Just in that very Amy way, it's like, no way, there's no way, very Boston, like, no way, no fucking way. You can't get me just in that very Amy way. It's like no way. There's no way very Boston like no way no fucking way You can't persuade me anything
And we're at this really fancy restaurant in May fair the check comes and Amy looks at me and goes we got this I don't go we got this is like three thousand pounds I'm like use of expensive dinner. So like no, no, no, we got it. So we're in the cab on the way back to the hotel And I go He got you I convinced you to pick up the check and if you look to me and she goes do you think and I go fuck yeah Yeah, I'm ready for you and said wait I paid for the check
Did I ever tell you that Simon? No, I did not Yeah, that's amazing. I find it he's weird to be around Darren, you know, because you you constantly worried that he might do something strange to your mind Yeah, so Simon to be around Darren, you know, because you constantly worried that he might do something strange to your mind. So Simon, your level of astonishment is greater on the sets of Star Trek or Mission Impossible as far as execution, scope of production. Probably Mission Impossible.
Yeah, right. Just because of the stuff that Tom Cruise does, you know, that we are witness to on the day of him jumping off a cliff on a motorbike or whatever. Oh, yeah. I mean, that just sort of is genuinely terrifying. Right, and your stunt crew and safety crew and second unit, all that stuff that just must be
like rocket scientists. Yeah, hundreds of cameras on, when we did the bike stunt, which is in Mission Impossible, Dead Rucki part one, there was a take he did where there were cameras mounted on the bike he was riding. So when he jumped off it, the bike just sort of cartwheeled away and caught him every time it spanned. And then they had to go down into the bottom of this quarry
and find the bike and retrieve the cameras and find which ones were still working. And sure enough, they picked up this incredible footage of him just sort of like disappearing upwards as the bike and retrieve the cameras and find which ones were still working. And sure enough, they picked up this incredible footage of him just sort of like disappearing upwards as the bike. That's crazy. That's crazy. That's crazy. The whole tea on all departments of those movies is just insane. So, by the way, you know, I just found yesterday that I've actually got a second unit. Oh, good for you. Yeah. So, super tiny. You just discovered it. Let's find a way. But it counts, but it counts.
So wait, listen, I want to talk about, so it was for Mission Impossible 3, JJ just called you out of the blue. JJ Abrams just called you out of the blue and object. Yeah, it did. Because of Sean of the dead, right? Because of Sean, he, me and Edgibah writing hot fuzz and the phone rang and it was JJ Abrams
and he just sort of literally said, hey, do you want to come and be in the measurements of all three? And I said, yeah, okay. Please, please. Yeah, okay, why not? And I didn't know. Let me finish. I'm just at me mate. I like the finish.
I was kind of in the same way. He emailed me about Star Trek and just said, do you want to play Scotty? I think he got bored of looking for someone and just, I get that other guy that I got last time. Wow. I mean, it is unusual to be part, it is unusual to be part of such big kind of iconic
friendships that are very different. Unless you're Harrison Ford. Unless you're Harrison Ford, that's right. Yeah, Harrison Ford, you're the king. You're the British Harrison Ford. I've heard that before. It's, thank you. When you say your biggest regret was hiring,
was hiring Beatman for Paul. That was a huge regret. Let's get to Paul. I was listening to Hayda the other day on the podcast talking about those jalapeno shooters. And you weren't there that day. It was me, Nick, and Hayda. And they gave us these tequila shots
with jalapeno juice. And we'd shot lava the next day. Oh my God. I'm glad you weren't there. I feel like the sake of your bottom. He doesn't remember where he was yesterday, so that's the good news. But you remember when we gave you a Teen Wolf 2 poster at the end? Yes, your rap gift. I do. We'll sign it. I do remember that. I was very warned by that. Where is it? Where is it Jason? I saw that. Binned. Yeah. We're in Binned. Binned. Immediately Binned.
I sold that. Bend. Yeah. Bend. Bend. Immediately bend. Okay. Jay, get that framed. How unbelievably rude.
No, I think it came framed. It was framed. But then you unframed it. I thought you told me you unframed it. It's you just sell it easier. It's the first roll of nothing else. Yeah. Wait, I want to go back.
So in 2009, you completed the second installment of your nerd trifecta, which again, is a real thing. With Star Trek, who helped you with your Scottish accent? Was it hard like do you have Scots in your family? Yeah, I married to a Scott and I had a glass region. So her dad helped me. Sean's married to a Scott too. Yeah. There you go. Nice ride. Yeah, we, yeah, we, I got help from the family on that, because they're the first people to. Although they kept trying to make me put, like, this is a Tordry little Scottish rudeness into the script.
I did actually try a few things, but JJ came up to me and said, I mean, they've got to understand what you're saying. Let's hear just a little bit. You have a rudeness thing you could say, since Scottish. I do actually say there's a famous Scottish, Glaswegian saying which is getty fuck. If you're instead of like, you know, shut up or get out of it, it's getty fuck.
And in the first Star Trek, I do actually say to Deep Roy who plays my little wingman, you hear me go getty. And I don't, so anyone who's Scottish would know exactly what I was about. Oh, that's great. That's great. Oh, wow. That's crazy. And then you got, get tiff. So anyone who's Scottish would know exactly what I was about. That's great. That's great. Oh wow. That's crazy.
And then you got to a right one, like in six months. Yeah, that was... How did you get to a right? That was like someone giving you the keys to a really, really expensive car. It was the hardest thing I've ever done, just because we had no time. And Justin Lin, who was the director,
who's a director, who's a brilliant, brilliant guy, but he's not a verbal communicator, and it was really hard to understand what he wanted at first, like he used to drive you insane. And there's some people now that start track beyond, sorry. Start track beyond, yeah. And myself and Doug Jung, we wrote that script together, but it was loads of fun. And Doug came to stay with me in the UK and we'd write during the day and then at night, we'd watch episodes of the original series
just to try and get little Easter eggs to put in. And we eventually ended up. I, you know, weirdly, it was the first time I'd faced the idea of being rewritten by someone else. And, that's a while. You know, we worked really hard on it and then our producer, Lindsay Coulden said, we're gonna get some fresh eyes on the script.
And I was like, what the fuck? Like, I never experienced that before. And I was so incensed and angry that, how dare you? Like, I think, you know, I come from my cushy little British film making background. Well, Sean's mom used to get fresh eyes about every two months, right? Is that right? LAUGHTER So what we did was we'd get... Justin Lin would send us the rewrites,
and then Dog and I would secretly rewrite them, and then send them back to Justin, and then Justin would deliver them to Paramount as his notes. So we would secretly rewrite the rewrites. If you're listening to this Paramount, then it'll work. Okay. That's fucking great. What a great way to rig the system in your paper. Yeah, that's why I just can't just get rewritten it all on Paul. No, and it shows no. No, the Lorenzo. No, we didn't. no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I'm not saying you're actually one of the most supreme comedy double takes. I have ever witnessed in any comedy forum.
It wasn't a joke that like it was the first time I'd really heard it said. And I was like, oh fuck. Why? You go, we go, you say something like, thank you, Agents, as I only go, call me Lorenzo. And we go, Lorenzo, I'm not, oh, fuck. And what? You go, we go, agent, you say something like, thank you, Agent Zoily, you go, call me Lorenzo. And we go, Lorenzo's oil, and you go, yeah. Then you sort of do this, like, you suddenly heard it for the first time. And it's just fucking sublime, Jason. It really is.
It really just, it's just textbook. It's not surprising that I remember a little of that because I think it was a night shoot, if memory serves. It was a night shoot, yeah. We were up on the ski ball with Sigourney Weaver. And Daos, as Kristen Wigg used to call it, Daos. Daos, that's right. So Edgar Wright, who we've already established
is one of your besties and does a lot of stuff. I didn't know this. I didn't know he wrote and directed Baby Driver. I love that movie. I love it. I love it. Really? I mean, that is a master. He had that script for a long time. Yeah. And I hear I heard you do somewhere and impression of him. Can you do just a little bit of Edgar? You're right. He'll listen to this and they'll kill me. He does listen to it. His voice is quite high. That's terrible. He gets quite drunk. Can he say he's talking to your ear, you're quite loud.
Oh my God. Oh my God. It was a right to come on the show now himself and effort. We got to get him on the show. He does. He does send me reviews of episodes sometimes and via text. Well, after my phone numbers still the same, where's my text? Not reviews, but he'll say, I really enjoyed it.
I could listen to you do that for nine hours. Nick does it really well as well. It's got it, it's very high. It's kind of like a tarot act tool. LAUGHTER Oh, my God. Oh. But he is, you know, I mean, I've kind of,
one of the luckiest moments of my life meeting at Gadjust because he is such an extraordinary talent. And, you know, I love him a bit, so I'm sure he'll forgive me for doing his voice. Quiet like this. We'll be right back. SmartList is supported by rocket money. Now, if are you like me, do you have kids that have apps on your, you kind of like share an account and it's,
I've noticed that I've got a bunch of apps that have not been used for years, as my girls are older now and these are like little tiny little toddler apps and I've forgotten that I'm paying for them. Do you know how much your subscriptions really cost, gang? Most Americans think they spend about 80 bucks a month on subscriptions,
but the actual total is closer to 200. If you don't know exactly how much you're spending every month, you need rocket money. Rocket money is a personal finance app that finds and cancels your unwanted subscriptions. Monitors you're spending and it helps you lower your bills all in one place. Over 80% of people have subscriptions they've forgotten about and chances are you're one
of them. Just like, you know, like a streaming app that you do watch a show that you no longer watch, it's still there costing you money, rocket money would help you figure that out. Now, they will also quickly and easily find your subscriptions for you and for any you don't want to pay for anymore. You just hit cancel. It's super simple. Rocket money. Well, cancel it for you. It's that easy. Rocket money also helps you manage all your finances in one place and automatically categorizes your expenses so you can easily track your budget in real time. You can also get alerted if anything
looks off. Over 3 million people have used rocket money, saving the average person up to a $720 a year sound. That could be you. Join the 3 million. Stop throwing your money away. Cancel unwanted subscriptions. Manage your expenses the easy way. Go to rocketmoney.com slash smartless.
That's rocketmoney.com slash smartless rocket money.com slash smartless. That's rocket money.com slash smartless. Rocket money.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from eight sleep. Now, did you know the temperature is one of the most important factors in improving your sleep quality? I bet you didn't. I did not and now I get it because I got one of these eight sleep things and I'm you didn't. I did not. And now I get it. Because I got one of these eight sleep things. And I'm going to tell you about that in a second.
But science has shown that your body temperature actually needs to drop in the early and middle part of your sleep and rise in the morning so that you can fall asleep fast and get more deep sleep. The pod cover by eight sleep fits on any bend like a fitted sheet. The pod cover by eight sleep fits on any bed like a fitted sheet. The pod cover, it improves your sleep by automatically adjusting the temperature on each side of the bed. Based on you and your partner's individual needs, it can cool down, it can warm up, and adjust based on the phases of your sleep and the environment that you're in. So, for instance, we have my wife and I am and she likes things a little cooler. I like things a little warmer.
Sometimes I like things a little bit cooler and she likes things a little warmer. Guys, the pod cover folks at 8th sleep, they figured all this out. I guess we're not the only couple like that. And also, I can wake up, I can track how well I slept. It'll tell me how great we both did me and pod cover together as a team had we get through the night. It's pretty great. Invest in the rest you deserve with the eight sleep pod. Go to eightsleep.com slash smart list and save $150 on the pod cover by eight sleep. That's the best offered you're gonna find,
but you must visit 8Sleep.com slash SmartList for that $150 off. 8Sleep currently ships within the USA, Canada, the UK, select countries in the EU, and Australia. And now back to the show. I remember like it was yesterday, although I'm not sure of some of the details, but I'm pretty sure it was a screening of hot fuzz that I believe you were there with me, Willie, that we got invited to and I met you and Nick and Edgar and Edgar or you, all you guys had loved to rest the development. Like that's why we were there. That's how we got invited. And then I remember that is being one of the
first times that I thought, oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, Judge. Oh, yeah, it was, it was the screening of extract. Extract. Extract. Yeah, that's it. Simon, did we go together or something? Were we met up there with Edgar or something? That's right. And then, then afterwards, we were in the bar and then you, me, Amy, and you guys and Amy and me. And there was some,
I remember there was some paparazzi shots of us all kind of like hanging off each other and smiling and drinking. And I remember there was some paparazzi shots of us all kind of like hanging off each other and smiling and drinking. And I remember being really just I drinking. I don't know. I was still drinking at that time. No, you weren't Jason. You were not. No, I was still I was still on it in those days, but no, what Paul's when you write when you got sober, right around that time? Just after Paul. Yeah, I was I was pretty drunk through Paul, but it was like a year off of that. I got drunk for you. Good for you. I have to fan out because I'm not going to have to use. Go, Sean.
So, Star Wars universe and Star Wars world and like growing up was that surreal getting like invited into that world and then like, you know, being around Carrie Fisher and all of those people. And was that you behind the thing for six portions. Was that you, that big guy? Yeah, that was me in the big fat suit, yeah. And was that all CGI? Was that just... They CGI'd my face a little bit,
just to make me look less human, but it was a big suit and... Yeah, he was called Oncar Plut. And he owned the Millennium Falcon, which is like, you know, I was very happy the fact that I have now owned the Millennium Falcon and been the engineer on the Starship Enterprise. I know, it's so insane, that's insane.
But wait, so growing up and were you a fan, and then now you're in it, and you're around Carrie Fisher, and Harrison Ford, I mean, were you like... Yeah, it was extraordinary. I mean, that set as well, the Force Awakens, because it felt very much like the first star, was the star was I grew up loving. And to be around those guys, I was on set the day when Harrison Ford and Hannon Chouy came onto the Millennium Falcon again for the first time. Crazy, I cried. I cried like a child.
And then I had a great, I've told this story before, but it's a good story, it's worth telling. I had a massive crush on Carrie Fisher when I was a kid. I mean, she was the first romantic love that I remember of feeling, you know, and I would kiss her picture before I went to sleep, and I was just so in love with her. Did you breathe return to the Jedi before even, you know... Well, you had a poster and you'd make out with a poster or something? I kind of kissed it quite sort of coily,
because I wasn't, I was seven, eight, I think I was, when I saw stars. It didn't get to the UK till 1978. So I'm on set with her and we're walking around this. Oh well, just like a world's face, just trying to come up with a, what, what would the poster that Sean has? Oh my, oh, oh, Sean? Yeah, to Sean. Light savers. She, she, we walk around the set of the resistance base, Arm and Arm, and I was kind of chatting with her and stuff.
And I stopped and I looked at her in her eyes and I said, you know, and the thing was, it was the same fucking eyes. It was the same. I know that's an obvious thing to say, but it was her eyes, the eyes that I had just dreamed of ever looking into as a kid. And I said, you know, I've always loved you, don't you? Oh, God. She grabbed my hand and she looked at my wedding and she went, fuck you. just dreamed of ever looking into his kid. And I said, you know, I've always loved you, don't you? Oh, God. She grabbed my hand and she looked at my wedding ring. And she went, fuck you. I thought, oh, nice.
Really? This is so funny. She was the best. She said, you know, the one thing she said to me when I first met her years and years and years and years ago, never met her in my whole life was sitting right next to her at this dinner. And she goes, you know, Han Solo and I were fucking the whole time.
And I was like, Blah! I was like, what? It completely shattered, like everything. There's that roast she did. I think it's a roast of Harrison Ford or something, but she starts talking and she starts talking about how nervous Harrison Ford looks
because he doesn't know what she's gonna say because obviously shit happened. All right, all right. Okay, so there you are. So now it was forced away. Can you say that what were you talking about? That was what I was in. Yeah, that's the force away.
Yeah, because that was like 30 years after the Battle of Endor, right? And, and- Fuck you, Will. No, hang on, I'm- Yeah. So they're on, I'm just trying to think, because there and, and, fuck you, Will. No, hang on, I'm, so they're on the, I'm just trying to think because, because there's that pilot, which is named Poe Dameron and he's on the desert planet of, of Jack who.
You look at it with the padi. Yeah. No, what? Yeah. He is. Okay. Oh, this is so boring. I can't believe they were on Jack who.
That whole time, that guy. By the way, did you notice, did you, did you, did you notice that some people say, in that movie, some people say, Jakku and other people say, Jakku. Of course I fucking noticed it, dude. It's Jakku. Of course. It's Jakku, right.
It's a double K, come on. Of course I noticed it and then I went and I bought a rope and I bought a chair and I was like, what would be a good spot for this? Fuck it, hell. Okay, give, but wait. I say that. Oh, I would love you knowing that love.
Wait, so sometimes, some so after the Star Wars are one of this 27 Star Trek, whatever, you said you, I read that you went on vacation and you said, don't, I don't want, you're told you're agent, I don't want anybody to bother me. No, I don't want any phone calls. Only if it's Steven Spielberg. Yeah, Steven Spielberg actually fucking all to you. And tell you what. Oh my God.
He phoned and said, will you come and be in Ready Player One? Yes, I love that movie too. And which is obviously an incredible call to get. And we'd work with him, you know, because he does a little cameo and Paul as well. So I'd work with him on 10-10 and then he came in and did his little bit in Paul. And then I got to do Ready Player One. And to work with him on Tin Tin and then he came in and did his little bit in Paul and then... And then I got to do Ready Play One and to work with him is a dream, you know.
He's just the most extraordinary. Yeah, of course. I mean, he's everything that I loved about cinema as a kid, and as an adult. And he's very willing to sort of chat about his career and stuff. He's really, really... I love that. Without crowing, you know, he'll just tell you stories about jaws and close and cannas. And it's just such a privilege, you know. He was at Sean's opening night.
Oh, did he go see a play? He's an investor, nice fella. Oh, wow. I know. He's been on the show. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Last year. Super nice.
Wait, so ready to play one. So then you talked a little bit about the English, you talked about a little bit like American humor versus English humor. And about a little bit like American humor versus English humor, and like how something about like, something about like how we always say, just kidding or something, but Americans like,
yeah, well that's sort of, there's a weird thing, and it comes from a lot of sort of snobbishness, snobbishness in British comedy circle sometimes, and that you hear our Americans, they don't do irony. And it's such a bullshit statement because Americans do some of the greatest irony ever. You guys just don't use it so much socially.
I present company accepted, I mean, Jason particularly, because you got a British mom, right? So you don't just try it and many it deserts. And I'm usually grumpy, so it's kind of a double negative. So yeah, you're virtually very hungry. He's hungry. So hungry.
But because British people are very ashamed of their emotions, they just wrap everything in sarcasm and are only that. It's socially, you know. But I think American people generally are just a little less uptight. And so if they do say something, try, they'll qualify it as just kidding, just in case that person thinks that they were being serious, which is very right.
But you only have to watch. I mean, arrested is a great example of a brilliantly dry comedy show. You know, it's... I actually started showing my 14-year-old daughter the other day, which was great, because it meant I could sort of go back to the beginning. And it's such a good example of dry American humor at its best. Yeah.
But it pales in comparison to all the money Python stuff, I mean, the British office. I mean, that whole style of not winking and just playing everything as a drama. Yeah. But a deeply flawed character in a drama. Like then you've got a real good humor. Yeah. Wait, so another mission impossible coming out soon on July 12th.
Are you guys just doing a row? Yeah, are you filming the second part now? We're in the midst of doing two in a row. Oh my God. We've stopped filming now so they can finish Dead Rekking Part One and then we go out on a big press tour over the summer. We'll be in New York, free tickets to your show, please. But the last go, I think it's Denny.
Any time you want. The last go, the Tabasco Theatre. The Tabasco Theatre. It's a hard sell on there. It's a fast, spicy show. And then we go back to shooting in August and then we complete Part Two, which will be our next year. And it's been a hell, I mean, we started shooting
this one in 2020 in the September of 2020. Wow. It's taken us three years to shoot this movie. Wow, that's amazing. Right in the thick of the hoax. I mean, we kind of, what did I say? You said hoax, yeah. I mean, Simon, you haven't say? You said hoax, yeah.
I mean Simon, you haven't stopped. You haven't stopped making great stuff. I know. Like 20 years. Yeah, I know. I mean, I... I want to get to that. Like do you geek out?
Like I would if I were you, when you get the scripts that you get or you produce or make. Like are you a fan of the genre like I am? And you know what I mean? Like you like, oh this is so cool. Yeah, I think I am, but I feel like I've aged you don't even mean like you like oh this is yeah I think I am but I feel like I've aged out a little bit of stuff that I I've not kind of kept up with all the new
sort of Star Wars TV shows and stuff yeah that's not to say that it's not because I I'm sure I have I catch you up just comment I'll catch you if you're ring afterwards. Well yeah Sam what kind of stuff are you watching comedy-wise? Because I'm trying to think if I watch any comedies, really, it's been a while. Is there anything that's kind of... I started watching the show last night. I think you should leave on Netflix.
Oh, yeah, yeah. I've heard about that. That's great. I'm writing it down. It's ridiculous. Yeah, it's really good. I just rewatched it with somebody. Because the episodes are like 16 minutes long. I've heard about that. That's great. I'm writing it down. It's ridiculous. Yeah, it's really good. I just rewatched it with somebody because it's so, because the episodes are like sort of
16 minutes long. They're not that long. And I just got one year in Atlanta. I got Eli to go through and I watched them all again with him and they were just brilliant. Yeah, it's really strange and but hilarious in a way that, in the way that like Python used to be, you know, like sort of slightly baffling. It's a pretty short show. No, sure, exactly why you're like Python used to be, you know, like sort of slightly baffling. It's a brilliant show.
Not sure exactly why you're looking. No, it's American. Shot here, Tim Robinson, brilliant, brilliant guy. And as you know, the very nature of, we have a lot of people from SNL on here over the years, the last few years, the nature of sketch comedy is that it's really inconsistent. It's so hard to, from sketch to sketch to always be strong or always be good. In that show, I think you should leave those first six episodes.
Oh, you told me about that. I can't. Oh, consistently good. Every sketch. You did watch it. Yeah, really good. That was a while ago. Yeah, really.
Simon, wait, I just, I'm sorry, this is the last mission possible question just because I'm a pro. Do you get to, because it's so, your character's so funny and like, it's so natural that do you get to write your own lines like are they cool with that? Because it sounds like not really. I mean we don't really have a script It's a very strange way of working really kind of make it up as we go along
I don't believe it but that's great. It's true. I have not ever read a script for the film I've just made What Tom and McQ Chris McQuarrion Tom Cruise they know the story they know the big set pieces script for the film I've just made. What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What?
What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What?
What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What? What? story kind of organically, as we go. But there's so come the pages. I know, we get pages on the morning of shooting stuff. And I have to say, where have I been in the previous scene? And where am I going?
And it can be frustrating, but it sort of works. And occasionally I get to kind of ad lib silly stuff. Like when we were shooting a scene for Fallout, when Tom was sort of guiding, I'm basically like a GPS, that's my job in the impossible, I just mean directions where Tom Cruise needs to go. And it was all the stuff about having the map upside down and the 3D thing, that was all kind of thrown in the moment. Oh, really?
Macu is a brilliant writer, you know, he's an Oscar-winning writer, he wrote the usual suspects and... What an incredible director. He just somehow thrives in that situation. Incredible, amazing. I love, I am so in love with those mission impossible movies, What an incredible director. He just somehow thrives in that situation. Yeah. Incredible. I love, I am so in love with those mission impossible movies. All of them are so, they're always great.
They're so good. And you're always great in them. I mean, yeah, it's so hard, you're so great in them. And it's hard to believe that something that has that kind of scope, as Jason said, that's so good and complex and stuff that you guys would sort of improvise in that way or not really have a full understanding to me on something so big. I don't know, I tell you where that wouldn't wash is on the oceanic planet of Achtel.
No way. You can close the wiki window. No, you wouldn't wait, build the other way. Yeah, we should shut that window down. No, no. Well, on that note. Beautifully done. Simon, you are like a dream.
We take it too much of your time. This is so nice. I know, guys. I feel like we just got started. Let's keep going with this. I don't know. We can do it too, partner. I know, I know.
Will you say hi to Nick Frost, please? I will, I will. Get him on. Edgaron, I, you know, who put me onto this podcast was Naira Park, who, you know, just, she produced Paul and, yeah, yeah. Oh, yeah. She's Edgar and Edgar and my producer. She's done everything we've ever done.
And last year, she said, Oh, you listen to Smartness, right? And I said, Oh, and... So I had the whole of the back catalog to sort of like, which I literally have been like, every time I go to the gym or every time I go for a drive. It's just become like the soundtrack. And then, like, however recently, the idea of actually doing it came up.
And, man, it's just so, I love you guys. I think you're so amazing. Have you ever got any ideas of people we should have on the show? Please let us know. Yeah. Yes, I'll send you some British people and you can do it. Please. Oh, it's great to see you, man.
Yeah. It's so nice to meet you, Simon, and such a fan. You too, Sean, it's a real pleasure. I'm serious about Comey's he could not ask her. I'd love to come see if I can. Anytime. Don't miss that. Yeah, you'll be blown away. Simon, we love you.
Simon. Okay. We love you. We love you. We love you. We love you. You slam it. You slam it. Yeah., slam it. All right. You said it, man. Love you guys. Bye.
Love you, buddy. Well, that's a, listen, that is a, that is a round peg and a round hole. Oh, nice. No. He said that peg's no square. No. What else? That's a really good actually.
Thanks, man. I'm coming up with a buy as we're, as we're talking. Are you there? I know what I'm thinking about is this friend of mine. I'm not kidding. This is not getting to a buy. This I've been trying to like connect the dots on. I was thinking about Scotty. Yeah. Because we were talking about Scotty. Yeah, I told him he I told him Simon Pag was going to be on the free top. And then remind me I never told you this because you might that I'm this is not a joke. One of my best buddies growing up is his name is Scotty Bear. And then I thought about your, I swear to God.
Oh really? Yes. That's funny because Scotty's a bear and you like bony bear. Right. So. I like Scotty's bone and bear. Yeah. So, wait, but Simon Pack, I've always wanted to meet him.
I can't believe you knew him. I didn't know you guys knew him. I knew you worked with him in Paul, Jay. meet him. I can't believe you knew him. I didn't know you guys knew him. I knew you worked with him in Paul, Jay. Yes. But I didn't know you knew him. He seems really fun. Jay's looking up a buy right now. So, I'm doing it.
Yeah, I'm finding that my brain needs to completely shut down and focus on that and I can't hear you guys right now. Jay, JB, how fucking weird is that? So, remember, you thought it was a screening of hot fuzz and that I remembered it was a fucking screening of extract and I remember going to the restaurant next door with Mike Judge and you and Amy and Simon. What does that say?
Is it say anything? I'm looking for something that might be good for me. Is there something good that I don't remember? It was a screening for me, my movie, that I'm thinking it was for him and his movie. Does that say something nice about me? No, are you trying to get me, like Brownie points? Trying to fill up my own ledger,
on side the ledger. No, I don't get it. No. You know, when I was as a kid, I used to, fuck me, you know, Star Wars. You know, this is gonna be, by the way, it better be amazing, because you are like, oh, uh, yeah, you know, Star Wars, you know, this is going to be, by the way, it better be amazing because you are like, oh, for 40 right now. It's already lost.
It's a good one. You know, when I was a kid, I was used to mix up the pronunciation of Luke Skywalker's mentor. I, I, I didn't know I didn't think it was Obi-Wan Kenobi. No, that's, no, no way. I thought it was. No way. I can't lie. No, it was Obi-Wan. no, no way. I thought it was no way. I can't buy.
I thought it was oh by one. Oh by one. Oh, all by one can only be in two malls. What? What's it? Sean. Oh, by oh by one can only be one can only be in two malls. Was that our out?
No. No. No. Smiles. Smiles. Smiles. Flies. Smiles is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Unjurf. Smiles. Flies. Janet Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Amjurf. [♪ OUTRO MUSIC PLAYING [♪ Smart, less. subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.